welcome to another technology tuesday
today i'm answering a question for one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
crap stuff who wrote in to say evan
carmichael thanks sir for this amazing
video could you possibly make a video
for those who want to hire
on odesk something like how to hire an
employee on odesk well crap stuff this
is a great question and
i love odess okay i have i have a man
crush on odesk i found such great people
to work with me on exciting projects to
do an amazing job and it's all remote
right nobody's actually sitting here in
your office doing stuff they're all
doing it on their own time when they
want but delivering i've recommended
odesk to a lot of different
entrepreneurs and people have had a hard
time finding the right people and they
wonder how how i'm so lucky compared to
them i have a different hiring process
okay i have a really different hiring
process and not just on oh this is what
i do bringing somebody on locally too i
think the regular hiring systems are
broken and somebody can look really good
on paper right you beef up your resume
some people can do really well in an
interview and they they freeze through
all the interviews but
they don't end up being a great worker
right he end up having to fire them
after three months and and i hate going
through that process
what's more important to me is i want
somebody who loves what we're all about
and is a worker and if you don't have
the answer you'll go and find the answer
that's what i think we need in
entrepreneurial businesses and i've
developed a system for how to find that
on odesk so i'm going to share it with
you and hopefully you can apply it and
be one of the lucky ones who get results
with odesk
so number one is have a skilled testing
question
whenever i post an ad on on odessa and
posting a job posting i always have
usually one big long ugly description
right i don't make it easy for somebody
to read through my job posting a lot of
the reason why is i'm not always a super
detail oriented person but i need my
teammates to be right i need people to
compliment that weakness in me and be
really
detail
oriented so i need them to read this big
job posting big ugly paragraph right and
in the middle
i have a skill testing question and it's
usually something really easy like how
many twitter followers do i have how
many youtube subscribers do i have some
were just buried it's totally random and
it's in the middle of this big chunky
paragraph this question and then people
have to answer that and i say answer
this question in the first line of your
application because what's going to
happen with odesk or anywhere else
people see a job and they apply right
they send their standard resume they
change the name on the cover letter most
of the time and send it to you what
takes them
two minutes of work takes you real time
to screen
right you have to screen all these
resumes you have to screen all these
cover letters and they're chewing up
your time and i hate having my time
chewed up so what i do is
i look for that first sentence
if you haven't told me how many twitter
followers i have you haven't told me how
many youtube subscribers or whatever my
skill testing question is you haven't
put that in your first sentence i'm not
reading your application i don't care
how good you are i don't care about your
background your credentials i don't care
about your references i don't care about
any of that because you're wasting my
time because you did not read my
paragraph
and the people who write in to say
what's your twitter account so i can
answer the question properly it blows my
mind if you can't go and type evan
carmichael twitter and find me
then i don't want to hire you either
so right away i cut out around 80
percent of the people who apply to the
job 80
imagine if i had spent you know if you
get if you get 100 applications and 80
of them are junk and you have to spend
five minutes on each one of those going
through how much time do you lose on
that it blows my mind so if you gotta
answer my question number one have your
skill test in question
number two is hire for a small job so if
you answered my question typically what
i'll then do is i again i don't care
about your previous work on odesk i
don't care if you're brand new i don't
care if you have 2000 hours on it
doesn't matter to me if you answered my
question then i'm going to hire you for
a small sample project and what i
usually do is set a project i set a
limit of five hours and i pay you for it
say hey i'm going to hire you to do this
project and it's a small thing that
relates somehow to what they're going to
be doing right so when i hired christina
who does my video editing i hired her
and i hired a bunch of people and i
hired them for five hours and said hey
here's one video
do what you can with it make it awesome
i give them five hours and what it does
is allow you to test to see
are people doing a good job or not so
first of all it lets me see
are they milking me for the full five
hours or not i actually try to find
something where i think it's going to be
less than five hours maybe it'll take
them three hours to do and so are they
gonna milk me for the full five hours
and say oh yeah i work five hours on
this so they can get the money grab
because i don't want that person working
for me and i just saved a whole bunch of
time figuring that out and i can
eliminate them right away or did they do
it ahead of time right if i say i need
it by done by saturday and here's five
hours to do it do they go all the way to
saturday and take five hours or do they
get it done by thursday and do it in two
hours right that's the hustle that you
want
and then you can look at the quality of
the work
is it good right do they blow you away
the reason why i hired christina is
because she did more than what i asked
her to do
most of the people who submitted it they
just did what i asked him to do they
took they took by intro they put it on
there they put the enter the end
whatever i asked them to do they did it
but they didn't go beyond
where christina said hey here's some
other things you can do with it and
created a new video and i loved it said
her i gotta hire her so always start by
hiring on a small job
and expanding from there number three is
keep the top performers so you'll find
that from that trial job a couple people
will send out it may only be one person
but it may be two or three people i hire
those people if it's one or three
on
a more full-time basis right i hire them
on an ongoing basis and i see who excels
because i believe that you get
a feel for working with somebody pretty
quickly and you can see are they really
working hard are they really pouring
their energy into this are they giving
all of themselves to this are they just
kind of floating by taking a paycheck
right i don't want to be
the guy
on odesk who has to look at your screens
and has to track your keystrokes right
odess gives you that feature you could
you could see everybody's screenshot i
don't want to micromanage people on
odesk or
somebody who is in my office i don't
want to have to manage those people i
want them to be motivated i want them to
work hard i want them to be passionate
what they're doing and so i find those
people
who want to do it and don't waste my
time on everybody else so remember
number one have a skill testing question
number two hire for a small job number
three keep the top performers and
believe
thank you for the great question if you
want to see more videos like this you
can subscribe to my channel and i will
see you soon